foreign
we have Chase in Atlanta Georgia hey
Chase welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me absolutely how
can we help
um I'm curious if y'all have any advice
on making a career change while you're
trying to pay off debt
um just a little back story about a
little less than a year ago I changed
careers to do something that I really
wanted to do uh something that I was
really passionate about but it was kind
of on a gamble of a part-time job that
would hopefully become full-time and it
has not become full-time yet
um and so my wife and I agreed that you
know it coming up on that year if it
wasn't full time I was gonna have to
figure figure out something full time
because we just need to be pulling in
more money yeah
um just so kind of just feeling a little
hopeless as that's coming up because
I've applied to a couple jobs and come
back
um my wife's been the provider mainly
you know I mean I'm working part-time so
she's been the provider for the past
year
um and just as a husband and as the you
know just spiritual head and everything
I want to be providing
um that's a really hard thing for me to
not have and so I'm kind of just unsure
of where to go
um yeah
I'll hop in and Rachel you hop in too is
that cool
um so first how old are you brother
I'm 26. okay so I want you I'm glad you
learned this lesson at 26. that's
awesome
um some of the stupidest wisdom of our
era our age that we live in is this
notion of Follow Your Passion
I'm just gonna go what the science tells
us is we become passionate about what
we're good at and what we're good at are
things that we have to practice over a
long period of time
and what that also tells me is if I get
a job as a podcaster or a YouTuber a
radio person like I have right now that
I wasn't particularly passionate about I
was really passionate about helping
people over time I've become super
passionate about this gig does that make
sense
and so it's finding out what's my role
what's my purpose but dude that can if I
got fired tomorrow if Dave just fired me
tomorrow and I was working at Burger
King this weekend I would want people to
have a little bit better day after
interacting with me than before right so
my my purpose for being alive would
still be intact it would just look very
different and I would I would I would
not be making as much money as I make
right now right so that's number one
number two
um I'm gonna challenge you to not
conflate leadership and head of
household with I make the most money I
think that's a dangerous path to go down
there's been seasons of my marriage when
my wife makes way more money than me and
it's been awesome because we're in this
thing together and there's been Seasons
when I make way more money than her and
it's awesome because we're in this thing
together but when you set yourself up as
I'm a failure or I am not doing X Y and
Z and so I'm not meeting some
I don't know I I don't get started on
that road but you're not meeting some
standard that you've invented or
probably somebody invented it and handed
it to you that usually comes out and
guys making a lot of immature decisions
or being angry a lot or being ashamed a
lot and there's no sense in bringing
that into your marriage so be really
really grateful that you have a wife
that's kicking butt and keeping you all
afloat I'm really proud of y'all for
putting a deadline on this thing putting
it putting a marker in the sand and
saying okay we're going to give this all
we got for a year and then we're gonna
have to Pivot and make another decision
awesome and you get to be really sad
that it didn't work out that sucks you
can grieve it and be bummed out about it
and then say cool
what comes next but it's not coming next
because uh here's what I think I think
you're adding those extra variables
those extra because I need to be this
and I gotta be this the extra pressure
because you're really sad that this
thing didn't work out is that fair
that is fair you I mean you hit the nail
on the head
um with the the anger and the shame
um of everything yeah for guys and Chase
I'll tell you that and John you can
speak into this for all the work we've
done around specifically just like men
and women when it comes to money for men
money is more of a scorecard there is
something tied to like a guy's worth of
saying oh my gosh this is this is what
I'm bringing in this is where we are
financially like there's something tied
with a guy even different than than a
woman
um it's like this identity piece and I
think whether it's been taught to you
like what John was saying or whatever it
is but like regardless of who you are
your net worth is not your self-worth
who chases the kind of husband you are
the kind of dad you might be or will be
in the future like who you are Chase and
loving your family and serving them and
doing what's best because what's what's
best right now is exactly what you're
doing of saying hey we've done this for
a year and it's not working I gotta go
find another job and it's not to fulfill
some role around that it's just to be
able to say yeah common sense is telling
us like I could be making more money
right now and yeah and and we're gonna
we're gonna decide that as a family so
um what's this passion job brother
uh graphic design
so if number one we're hiring so if you
want to submit your application for
graphic designers here go to Ramsay
that's exactly right
um but two that sounds like one of those
jobs that you can do just absolutely
knock out of the park you can even work
from home in certain situations you can
do a great job continue to keep your
practice on the side and I don't see
this this dream as being dead at all I
see it being as not right now or I've
got to get some more skills under my
belt or I've got to learn the business
side of this thing and so working for a
an agency or a company is going to be a
way I get a grasp on the business side
of this stuff
um like it just tells me that at 26 you
got a lot to learn and by the time
you're 36 dude it's it's lights out
that's a game changer so this thing
isn't over my brother not even a little
bit are you guys working the baby steps
chase you and your wife or y'all trying
to pay off debt where are you guys at
financially
yes we're on baby step two we have about
30 000 in student loans right now and
that's it okay great how much have you
guys paid off so far
uh we paid we paid off about 10. nice
awesome well good well you're on you're
on the track so do this it's gonna sound
cheesy but I'm gonna tell you but I want
you to do it uh anyway is that cool
yeah absolutely all right I want you and
your wife to hold a tiny little funeral
service
for this passion dream that you had
this I like it I'm gonna launch but
here's why it's gonna it might be silly
but I want y'all to go all in on it go
all in
and invite friends if you've got them
that would be a part but kind of on the
inside joke of this whole thing but also
not really a joke here's what it's going
to give you it's gonna give you and your
wife a marker
this is when this we we as a family
shifted we closed this door and we begin
opening other doors and that's a
powerful moment otherwise it just kind
of lingers and you take your new job but
you're still kind of checking your other
work email to see if clients come in and
you never fully go from one place to the
other you just kind of get you're
everywhere so have a funeral for it say
we are done and we are now making this
transition and then take your wife out
to breakfast and I know we tell you in
baby step two don't do that but you're
making a major life transition take your
wife out to breakfast actually I don't
kick you while you're down but she'll be
taking you out to breakfast I know that
wasn't cool but it's true she's gonna
take you out to breakfast and I want you
all to sit at the table and then dream
together okay
what's our Sprint through this last
thirty thousand dollars we're gonna take
two jobs three jobs we're gonna get this
thing knocked out we're gonna You're
Gonna Stand Tall you're gonna walk tall
you're not gonna dump the anger and
shame onto her and you're ready for this
whole new transition stay on the line
we're gonna get you Ken Coleman's get
clear assessment I'm gonna give it to
you as our gift and it will broaden your
horizons and what you can do with your
graphic design dreams